The city streets are crowded for the holiday
even with the rain hidden in the chaos is the
element waiting to strike like snakes welcome
back everyone this is going to be my top 10
questions from the batman movie hopefully you've
had a chance to see the movie at least once or
twice by now there were a lot of huge things that
we have to talk about there are some follow-up
questions we are doing an imax ticket giveaway
so you can go back and watch a bunch more times
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and post your biggest question after the movie
in the comments careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the movie yet we'll be talking about
everything that happened starting with number 10
what did barry keoghan's version of the joker do
that was so bad that it got him thrown in arkham
asylum by batman instead of the regular prison for
common criminals and has he been through a version
of the accident that turned him into the joker
even though they explained during this movie he's
not calling himself the joker like he hasn't fully
become the joker yet i've already talked about
the deleted scene that he had with batman like
they did a version of a batman vs joker scene
in arkham when batman came back to interrogate
riddler before the big final attack on the
election they have a brief interchange like he's
trying to provoke batman and batman doesn't want
to have anything to do with him like he's just
trying to focus on what's happening with riddler
and what's been happening for the past week or so
this is long before he develops the joker toxin
this is long before he starts wearing the makeup
you have to remember that arkham isn't just
a prison for really dangerous criminals
it's a prison for the really dangerous villains
who are mentally insane so if you think about
heath ledger's joker this is a really good
example like he pulls off that really badass heist
at the beginning of the dark knight movie he
killed a bunch of people he was using a lot of
clown paraphernalia all those clown masks the way
i imagined it is that barry keoghan's character
tried to pull off a heist that was smaller
than that and was not using a lot of clown
paraphernalia and maybe only a couple people died
or almost died like it wasn't as big a disaster
as what was happening during the dark night with
that version of the heath ledger joker i think a
lot of his conversation with the riddler trying to
console him after batman reigned on his parade so
to speak was also a little autobiographical like
he was also speaking from experience like batman
reigned on his parade the joker's parade and for
a little while he felt like the city actually
feared him but then they kind of viewed him as
a clown but he was telling the riddler there are
worse things than being and he kind of trails
off he was going to say there are worse things
than being a clown so he wasn't just telling the
riddler to not worry about feeling like a clown
he was also sort of talking to himself in that
way too like it wouldn't be so bad to be a clown
and then eventually he will become the full clown
version of the joker wearing the makeup and the
full-on get-up he'll embrace that next one what
is the riddler's rataalata.com website counting
down to so it's a real website if you didn't
know you can actually go visit it ratalata.com
and it's actually counting down to something that
started just a couple days ago my early theory is
they would just release some extra content or
there'd be some deleted scenes maybe the joker
deleted scene so just keep that in the back of
your mind it is counting down to something some
sort of content that they'll release through that
viral website but number eight which other batman
villains are currently in arkham asylum right now
assuming pretty much all of them are still getting
versions of their origin stories too at this point
in the timeline and which of those characters are
we gonna see during the batman arkham hbo series
probably mr freeze because matt reeves has already
talked about him maybe scarecrow he'd still be a
doctor working at arkham probably experimenting
on patience developing his fear toxin and also
probably harley quinn she'd still be dr harleen
quinzal at this point in the timeline too number
seven follow-up too matt reeves said that he would
love to introduce a new version of harley quinn
in this universe into an origin story for her
who would that be it definitely wouldn't be margot
robbie's harley quinn given that all the spin-offs
the hbo series the sequels are going to be in the
same tone of this very noir batman universe the
world's greatest detective batman universe i think
this version of harley quinn would be a little
less over the top than margot robbie's version of
the character just like a little bit more subtle
imagine a slightly more realistic version of
batman the animated series done in live action
but he did say that most of these other big batman
villains would be featured during the arkham
series number six there were so many scenes of
batman saving children in the movie particularly
the mayor's son a couple times in the film and
scenes of that skull gang member played by the
tim drake actor from titan's catwoman going to
bloodhaven where dick grayson is from will they
ever introduce one of the robins during the robert
pattinson era of batman even if it's not till he's
much older later in his timeline they kind of did
that with the christian bale dark knight trilogy
if you haven't seen the dark knight rises
in a while joseph gordon-levitt played a
character called john blake who as a child had an
encounter with batman one night it inspires him to
eventually become a police officer one day and he
later works with batman during dark knight rises
to take down bane at the end of the movie batman
leaves him the mantle of the bat the bat cave all
of his batman gear in his will and it's revealed
that his legal name was actually robin so it's
very on the nose he's not dick grayson but he's a
version of dick grayson you have to remember that
right now in this first movie he's in his late 20s
i believe canonically batman adopted dick grayson
and he became robin during his third year
as batman this movie is batman year two
and i don't think that matt reeves is ready to
have robert pattinson's batman adopt a child
in the next batman movie so if we do see a robin
i'm assuming that they'll use the same christopher
nolan tactic where you won't really hear about a
robin character taking up the mantle of the bat
till the final film number five how did the
penguin get all of his scars we knew during this
movie he was carmine falcone's right-hand man he'd
been working with him for a long time the way they
explained the penguin name in this universe is
that it's used as more of a derogatory term at his
character after that amazing batmobile car chase
scene where they capture him and then question him
they tie him up but then they just take off and
leave him without untying him he kind of waddles
out a little bit like a penguin his story inside
this universe is going to be a little bit like
the scarface movie he'll be like the tony montana
of this batman universe my assumption just based
on the scars on his face is that he just got into
a really bad fight when he was younger and that's
what disfigured him post all your heath ledger
joker memes do you want to know how i got these
scars number four if robert pattinson's batman did
not go to nanda parbat to train with ra's al gul
in the league of assassins before becoming batman
alfred said in the movie he was the person who
trained batman how to fight if that wasn't clear
that's where he learned all of his techniques
does a version of the league exist in this
universe is there a version of racial ghoul
that they'll use at some point between the sequels
and the hbo series i understand why matt reeves
wanted to swerve on ra's al gul and that part of
the origin story during this universe he didn't
want to remake batman begins that was a great
movie but that doesn't mean that they couldn't do
league of assassins or racial ghoul in one of
these hbo spin-off series number three if the
batman movie takes place on earth 2 separate from
the main dceu justice league connected movies will
they reference robber pattinson batman during the
flash movie when the flash travels the multiverse
to get to the earth that michael keaton's batman
comes from during the big comic con presentation
they did for the flash movie at dc fandom a couple
years ago they actually did this big montage of
all the different dc movies with all the different
actors going back 30 plus years so it says they're
trying to use the flash movie to canonize
everything through the multiverse the same
way that spider-man no way home canonized toby
maguire andrew garfield the venom movie same idea
but with all the dc movies matt reeves said that
he had no plan to introduce a version of superman
or any meta humans any super powered individuals
inside his batman universe so he doesn't have
plans to reference the multiverse from the batman
stuff but that doesn't mean the other dc films
won't ever reference robert pattinson's batman so
for those of you asking which batman is supposed
to be the main batman in the movies right now
if you're talking about crossover batman like
who's the batman that's going to be showing up in
all the big justice league films that they do in
the future right now at least it's supposed to
be michael keaton's batman but just behind the
scenes at warner brothers they are viewing robert
pattinson as the true future of batman at dc like
when you think about who their most important
batman is to them it is supposed to be robert
pattinson's batman it's just that they also need a
crossover batman to show up during these big films
because they want to do future justice league
team ups and you can't do a justice league movie
without a version of batman so michael keaton is
more like the older wiser batman beyond version
of bruce wayne still hoping for a batman beyond
live-action movie with a version of terry mcginnis
number two which other big batman villains
or characters will get their own hbo series
so easy pick is probably catwoman pretty much
all the major characters that they've already
introduced probably the court of owls eventually
matt reese said that he would also love to do
a version of the hush character even though
there were a lot of batman hush references in
the movie that i talked about in my breakdown
videos the reporter character that was killed
by carmine falcone for thomas wayne was not the
actual thomas elliott hush character there were
just a lot of references to the hush storyline
but not the actual hush character so he's still
free to show up in future films like i said pretty
much every batman villain is solid enough to get
their own hbo series with the right creative force
behind it like james gunn could even make a badass
version of a condiment king hbo series just look
at what he did with peacemaker like nobody cared
about that character at the suicide squad movie
then after the peacemaker series people are like
holy crap this is amazing because they already
have two hbo series in development right now
they'll probably wait till after the batman sequel
movie in like three or four years to plan more hbo
series because like mr freeze for instance in
court of owls both would make amazing hbo series
especially the court of battles but they can't
really do those until they introduce them for the
first time in the universe officially introduce
them all the actors have been hyping up cordova so
much in the past week it just feels like they have
big plans for them at some point in the future
thomas and martha were leaders of the court
of owls in this timeline i like that one oh
that's a i was definitely kind of thinking the
quarterback is probably going to be in the sequel
it definitely seems nice mommy i'm literally just
guessing i just keep saying it good thing it's not
in this film or is it or is it so number one wtf
what is going on with the actual court of owls in
this universe and will they actually be the final
boss of this batman trilogy or will that be the
joker my personal preference is i would rather
see matt reeves try to use different villains
than had been done before as the final bosses of
the movies yes i do want to see this batman versus
this new joker but we've seen batman versus so
many different jokers so many times in the past
10 years there are so many versions of the joker
right now and i'm sure barry keoghan is going to
be amazing as this version the joker but there are
so many amazing batman villains that they've never
done in the live-action movies the court of owls
are just one of the easiest slam dunks in order to
be a good final boss for a trilogy the villain has
to be smarter more insidious more powerful more
fearsome than all the batman villains who have
come before they have to be a huge upgrade threat
and because it's the last movie in a trilogy their
storyline has to be connected deeply to batman's
history and bring his story full circle the court
of alice does that their storyline reveals a true
dark history of gotham more dark truths about
batman's parents and his family going way back
generations that he never knew their storyline
shakes his reality in a really fundamental way
like my life as i knew it has kind of been a
lie the riddler teased a little bit of that
with the dark history of the wayne and the arkham
families when he was trying to out thomas wayne
but court of owls is like a much bigger more
profound version of that for the entire history of
the wayne family in the arkham families in gotham
if you have any big questions about the movie or
what's happening with the sequels the hbo series
that i didn't address in this video just write
them below in the comments i will do a bunch more
bonus videos this week i'm just waiting a couple
more days because some of it's really spoilery and
i think people are still trying to see the movie
everyone click here for my full breakdown of the
batman movie with all the easter eggs from the
entire film and click here for my video about that
joker scene and the ending in the post credits
scene thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!